the insider report brought to you by the
2017 Honda Fit with four unique seating
modes it is perfect for taking your
friends to the tailgate and carrying all
of your gameday gear to the fun and
flexible fit from Honda he is John
McLean good to see you sir
it's always fun to be on with you rich I
have people ask me say what is Rich
Eisen like behind the scenes and I say
he's just genuine behind the scenes is
he is on the scenes what you think he is
is what he is okay that's about he's
nice and things I can say and I
appreciate the star like you I
appreciate you saying that John thanks
very much so first things first is
everything okay in your world down in
Houston there's a lot of people whose
lives have shattered and you know rich
there's parts used to look like a war
zone
and as know it can be a multi-million
dollar mansion and it could be a house
from the 50s and they've done everything
stacked up on the streets you can go
down some streets and it really looks
like the bomb went off because
everything that's been pulled out of
homes they finally got the roads back
it's business as usual for people have
to use our freeways but there's a lot
it's going to take months and months to
recover and everything with you
personally we were very lucky I was with
the Texans at New Orleans and Dallas I
felt guilty my wife was there trained
for consecutive days but we had new
drainage put in our neighborhood mm-hmm
about five years ago and she said it
barely came over the curb no kidding we
were very very fortunate yeah knock on
wood no question about that
so how has that did that affect the team
in their performance in week one
no I there's no way that perfected him
because they knew what they faced
Jacksonville did not the Jaguars were in
a situation like the Texans were in New
Orleans when they didn't know what was
going on so here's the Jaguars not
knowing when they were going home what
they were gonna confront when they got
home and they were outstanding on
defense yeah and they didn't go home
until Tuesday as well I mean they they
would be they were in Houston for a
while so what I guess what what was the
problem for the Texans on Sunday was it
line play I think it's a bad combination
their outfits of the line
was awful and not not all the ten sacks
were up with the Lions fault but they
didn't run well they didn't use a rookie
Deonte Foreman but one carry for four
yards and he was the best back they had
in preseason that's bad coaching they
got away from the running game the
defense which is what everybody thought
would carry them had no sacks no
turnovers only gave up 280 yards bortles
only threw for 125 but they they look
poorly coach poorly prepared and I watch
them I know they're prepared but they
needed to go out behind a stadium and
all stick their finger down their throat
throw it up and move on and if they have
the same problems in the offensive line
against the Bengals tonight that they
had last week with the Patriots a trip
to New England coming up they're looking
at a no three record in a losing season
yeah I mean I tend to agree with that
and I think John they're in trouble
tonight because of a couple of things
I'm assuming let's start with one -
Shawn Watson's gonna get his first
career start tonight I was I would have
gone back to tom savage I can understand
why they played Watson in the first game
Savage could not escape the rush the
offensive linemen were getting
obliterated say but Watson in because he
has mobility but on a short week when
you have one legitimate receiver your
entire tight end core is wiped out
because of concussions and that's the
time you go with a veteran not on a
short week with a rookie and I would
have gone back to savage and Plus Watson
has a little ankle injury he tested it
he's fine but he's gonna be running so
much for the Bengals he might hurt it
again and savage have to come back in
well and I want a pin in that put a pin
in that part of it right to start right
now I mean here on the show you know and
because the idea is well that I
mentioned - with the the number of of
tight ends that that that have been hurt
and can cause anything like all right so
all your supposition though I doubt in
in one in one week no no I never have in
40 years and all wood concussions so
they've they've activated a kid or
undrafted free agent named Evan Bayliss
and then you'll see offensive lineman
playing tight ends and I've never seen
that but that's
still my excuse to play as bad as they
play I know there's that too and then
and then the fact that Brian Cushing is
now out for ten games and and now you
find out that a leader right there in
the middle of the front seven is gone is
it safe to call him the quarterback of
the defense bill O'Brien's always call
him the heart and soul now the
communication device will go to Bernard
McKinney the other inside linebacker
Cushing wouldn't played for a while
anyway yeah bad concussion and I think
he'll come back and play as the last
five games and I think that'll be the
end of his career in Houston and he is
the heart and soul of this defense he
sets the tempo he doesn't make big plays
like he used to but he means a lot to
the defense in a lot of ways that don't
show up drop it into coverage play in a
run and they drafted a second-round pick
exact Cunningham to eventually replace
him well it's kind of have to be sooner
rather than later and then he got an
undrafted free agent named Dylan Cole
who made the team those two guys got to
replace Brian Cushing John McClane with
Houston Chronicle here in the Honda
inside a report live from Cincinnati now
let's get back to the quarterback stuff
with Bill O'Brien now the show open you
heard you know I asked Michael Lombardi
fees the Keyser söze of quarterback
gurus by that I mean somebody that has a
huge reputation but you don't know if he
really exists well here's the deal about
Bill he had Tom Brady and Brady swears
by him Tom will tell anybody and
everybody what a great quarterback coach
the offensive coordinator bill was with
him and then he goes to Penn State he
has Matt McLuhan and hemoglobin plays
really well Bills national coach of the
year then the next year he has a true
freshman Christian Hackenberg replaced
so well everybody says when this kid
comes out he's going to be the first
pick of the draft and Bill leaves but
here he Bill's been Captain Hook he said
he just has a quick trigger for
quarterbacks and and we're not really
surprised in Houston that he did this
because he did it to Brian Hoyer two
years ago but the fact is in Watsons got
a chance to be special he's going to
struggle he doesn't have a talented
offensive line he's got one legitimate
receiver the running game is suspect
because of the line it is not an ideal
situation to
play rukiye quarterback especially when
you think you can win the division for
the fifth time in seven years but they
might as well get on with the Watson era
but there's a chance they'll go back to
savage cuz that's what Bill does no I
know that but speaking of somebody like
yourself John who's been around
quarterbacks who learned the playbook by
the light of a jukebox and have been
around all different types of
quarterbacks and people who coach
quarterbacks and people who draft
quarterbacks is Bill O'Brien a guy that
you want at the wheel when when you're
looking for a quarterback for a team he
hasn't shown that so far the last good
quarterback they had people in Houston
shudder when you say this but Matt shop
didn't have four good years when he and
Andre Johnson were one of the top one
two punches in the league but the last
great quarterback we had was Warren Moon
and they traded him in 1994 and that is
a long time to wait and we think based
on what we've seen and we know about
Watson he's got a chance to be special
but he does a moon struggle from 84
through 86 three years in which he
struggled and then then he went to the
playoffs seven years row now he's in the
Hall of Fame
they don't today rich you know everybody
wants instantaneous success sure he
can't wait three years anymore so
deshaun Watson how do you think he is
going to acquit himself tonight or do I
think if he had the Cowboys offensive
line and Ezekiel Elliott receivers he
would be really good but he doesn't
they're not walking through that door to
you he's going to be running for his
life a lot and he's really strong
mentally and I'm he's smart he works
hard he's got a better arm than
advertised
but he is not able to he's not gonna be
able to do what you want a quarterback
to do because of the surrounding cast so
what do you think happens tonight when
it all comes down to it I think it'll
probably be one of the most boring games
you've ever seen no no let's let's skip
that because it's Thursday Night
Football on the NFL Network at six
o'clock Eastern executives are so happy
to shot Watson's Kearney tell me about
it
tell me about it
to tell everyone about it no but okay so
it's a bad game a boring game and then
what do you think they're gonna they'll
run the ball a lot they got to get Joe
Mixon going for the Bengals they played
three backs last week and they need to
take pressure off both quarterbacks Andy
Dalton played worst game his career now
he's playing against the hometown team
they've seen him a lot
I expect their offense will be much
better because it has been in the past
if the Texans are gonna make a game of
this it's got to be because of the
defense as the last time they came in
here won 10 to 6 mm-hmm
I want to take a break come back and hit
the Astros with you the Rockets have a
big season that's about to start with
training camp with Chris Paul now in the
mix new owner for the Rockets as well
somebody I'm sure that you know from
around town and then as well just
hitting some other items around the rest
of the league and what you think
Super Bowl 50 my 52 might look like
that's a John McClain who is here that
was the Honda inside a report 844 204
rich is the number to dial we will take
your calls along with coleus Campbell's
when he calls in in about 12 minutes
time that's all going down here from
Cincinnati and the Rich Eisen show here
on Thursday night football kickoff 2017
the best pillows on the market are my
pillow calm it is the best night's sleep
around and the reason why is because the
pillow is made for the style of sleeper
that you are if you like sleeping on
your side or your back there's a pillow
specifically for you and you sleep like
a baby the 4-pack specialist 50% off
free shipping on to my pillow premium
pillows and to go anywhere pillows my
pillow comm promo code rich at my pillow
calm and then also of the phone number
eight hundred six one three five nine
seven four that's eight hundred six one
three five nine seven four John McClane
is here from the Houston Chronicle for
another segment coleus Campbell of the
Jaguar just got a call from the Jaguars
Doug Marrone is keeping him on with
field longer so he's not gonna be able
to join us today what's the matter with
these coaches he's making sure he's
gonna get another four sacks against the
Titans you know it's amazing that the
Jaguars could be the only team in the
AFC South with a win by the end of this
week with a two-game lead over three
teams that's entirely possible their
defense when you think about all the
high picks and all the money they've
invested in Campbell and AJ boy yay and
they were sixth overall last year you
know their defense was good based on
what I saw I think a lot of it is their
defense has a chance to be great you
know Campbell to start off with four
sacks he just abused the Texans
offensive line and and he was never
known as a great pass rusher with the
Cardinals he was a really good defensive
lineman played to run great right now
he's on a pace for what 60 Hemi sacks
yeah exactly he played to texans every
week he's going against a much better
off than supply sure if their past runs
can beat up the Titans offensive line
that's gonna be really impressed yeah
that's for real so who's the best team
in the NFL do you think John
obviously Chiefs are gonna go 19 and oh
I said the Patriots we're gonna go and I
meant the Chiefs right
I know swap them out maybe the Rams
scored the most points
coach fix it Wade Phillips goes in there
it is amazing the way he turns around
defenses in one year his every defense
he's been to his weight can point out
has been has gone from bad or he
wouldn't be there to being great did it
in Houston 30th the second I think and
when I saw them scoring touchdown
safety I thought coach fix it I texted
him to congratulate him and I'm really
happy for him and that's without Aaron
Donnell
I know he gets him back this week that
Sean McVeigh said he's gonna definitely
play this week against the Washington
Redskins and and then off we go here
we'll see though I mean Scott tolls een
looked like one of the worst
quarterbacks I have ever seen in in an
NFL uniform you wonder how could they
have any position to start the NFL they
got started Kobe presented they
announced that yeah maybe they want no
they haven't no keep that under wraps we
all know that he's got to start for
certainly in the Arizona Cardinals or
what tear would would tear toll Zeen
limb from limb they gotta get somebody
that at least is gonna start running
around but who is the best team do you
think in the NFL well based on what I
saw in the first game at Foxborough the
way they abused the Patriots I would
have to say the Chiefs now I don't think
six months from now they will be but man
oh man that was impressive what about
the Cowboys the Cowboys I mean you
expected what surprising about Dallas
was Rod Marinelli defense who would have
thought their defense they got guys out
suspended would just totally dominate
the Giants like that and the Giants are
one of the numerous teams that are
really suffering on their offensive line
yeah I earned it maybe is that a week
one thing that these that that unit of
any unit of any part of a side of a ball
of the NFL is the one that needs the
longest to gel and thus preseason isn't
even long enough for these guys well we
may say that look what Minnesota did we
made jokes about all these offensive
line being so overpaid in free agency
they were hurt and we're coming off
ineptitude injuries and now next year
imagine what they're gonna get because
colleges are not producing the shirt
things in the offensive line like they
used to you remember rich when a guy
goes at the top 15 a tackle or a guard
he's gonna play for 10 years now he goes
to the top 15 you can't count on him
till you get a minute coach them and see
how they're doing because they're just
playing so differently in college than
they used to yeah hey we've got two John
McClain here for a few more minutes here
in the Rich Eisen show Cincinnati
studio prior to tonight's game we've had
AJ Hinch on a couple times on the show I
love talking him he just needs a great
talker he well he also just seems like
he's got a great mind and the type of
guy that I would want to be in a dugout
with all of these young guys and now
here comes Verlander who has been lights
out he sure has since he was acquired
what do you think of the Astros chances
now that you know about the juggernaut
that's across state here with the
Indians the Indians may never lose
they're better than major league right
now what I'm stunned is they're not
selling out the ballpark every night
like they should be considering how
great they are and what did you see the
stat they've only trailed in for a tings
during this winning streak and they're a
Ras less than - yeah - drones were back
on the road to recovery they go to
Oakland it stink it up and lose four
games to the worst team in American
League Yankees did - earlier this year -
what is it with the day he's bring up
all these young guys and all of a sudden
they're good Verlander is the only good
thing they got going on their pitching
staff Dallas Keuchel has not pitched
consistently well the way he's used to
Lance McCullers scratched because of a
tired arm and then her Lander I've
watched every pitch he's thrown he has
been incredible and I can't wait until
he gets a Kate Upton sighting watch
maybe he you know you know what you know
honey what matters how to keep score
right with Kate Upton in the in the
Minute Maid yes of course has she been
there yet now yet he's been he's had
playoffs that's what's gonna be and
maybe saving if you watch I'm getting
you help she's busy and she's working
it's just making money but he came in
and was ingratiated himself so well with
the players they showed him constantly
in the dugout everybody's saying great
things about him and when he gets into
playoffs nothing's gonna be too big for
him because he's been in so much they
think when he and Keiko as their first
two pitchers they can go up against
anybody they thought it would be Lance
McCullers but since the all-star break
when he was on the all-star team he's
been on the DL and pitch worth of darn
so they're still looking for that third
you got to have so let's just say there
go against the Red Sox in that first
series do they throw a Verlander first
you think I think if you're gonna get
sale you got to Keuchel and steal your
guy and I think it would be an insult to
Keiko who's been their ace now he's got
to pitch the first game Verlander has
got a pitch the second game unless Keiko
can't get it together between now to
start of the playoffs and then what
about the Rockets John McLane of the
Houston Chronicle are they a super team
what do you think we're pumped about the
Rockets because you know they were
pretty good last year and in Daryl Morey
their general managers like a mad
scientist he's in there he's concocting
all these things Daryl's got to answer
his pants when it comes to the roster
and to to bring in Chris Paul has just
got everybody so excited he and hard
they're best friends I got a really good
commercial out there and people are
pumped about him
they didn't have to give up anybody they
didn't want to give up so people are
fired up their new owner Tillman 42
Tillman is owns casinos you can't own
NFL team of course at one point he was a
Texans minor partner and they had to buy
him out because he opened his casino in
Vegas now he's got one in Louisiana and
he's to pay 2.2 billion we were shocked
that Tillman could do that but he owns
about every restaurant in the world and
he's he's we like him he's not gonna be
quiet behind the scenes it's not his
personality he's going to be an out
front guy but they hope they're like les
Alexander he can be out front get
publicity but don't mess with the
personnel good owners don't do this well
I read that that Steve Ballmer his two
billion to buy the Clippers was like
four percent of his net worth not the
two billion of 42 is like 70% of his net
worth but he's putting all those 42 with
where the Rockets are pretty much what
he's wanted to own a team and he and
he's a Houstonian he wants to own a team
in Houston this was his chance he put
his money where his mouth was and Foom
Leslie Alexander is sold to him people
in Houston rich are really fired up
about having 42 when Leslie aiexander
bought
samia's from New York and we're like the
last New Yorker was John McMullen with
the Astros and he was awful
just terrible so people were very
suspect to less than they went to
Championships right off the bat he
turned out to be an incredible owner and
you know you want a donor who's gonna
spend money and he's gonna stay out of
it hire good people let him work and
they've got a good group in their front
office and so I think for Tito we'll sit
back and and have fun at the games and
enjoy it and plus it's great it's a
great thing for all of his restaurant
business I'll tell you that
last one for you John you've been in the
Houston scene since 76 76 you seen him
you've seen greats come and go and and
and do their thing where does JJ Watt
rank on the pantheon of Houston athletes
and personalities I've covered it and
watched a lot of people are in the Hall
of Fame and JJ he had those three
incredible years which he tied Lawrence
Taylor for NFL Defensive Player of the
Year awards I think that he's gonna win
the Walter Payton NFL men of the Year
award because of his incredible what he
did to raise money it's over 33 million
now and he's actually out distributing
it to make sure that people know where
it goes he has a chance to be Comeback
Player of the Year and if he was great
he could win the fourth Defensive Player
of the Year all at the honors show
before the Superbowl but he's got a
really good chance to be the man a year
to come back of the year and he's 28 now
coming off to back surgeries
nobody knows if he can be great again he
feels great until we see it on the field
people still gonna have questions about
it so then who is the greatest athlete
in Houston sports history here's some of
them Nolan Ryan AJ Foyt team Olajuwon
Earl Campbell there's been so many if I
had to pick one I'm partial I'd say Earl
Campbell it's hard to beat Nolan Ryan
and Liao's want helped him win two
championships and to me to be to be
great you got to do it over a long
period of time but I'm partial to Earl
because when Earl's first three years 78
through 80 he was as good a running back
as I've ever seen well
I know yet others in our business
tugging at you to join their show so I
appreciate you coming on this my
pleasure rich I wouldn't take anybody so
over you I love coming on with you I can
and I hope your all your listeners when
they go
what does Rich Eisen really like just
like you say I'm a jalebi a lot of fun
to have a beer with well what's up or a
glass of wine with you yes I'm I am more
of the red big boom and Brunello
Cabernet but I'd love the I P I'd love a
good IPA to and I'll take very much no
thanks for coming on and we Texans come
out to play the Rams have you on in the
Los Angeles that looks great I can't
wait
thank you that's John McClain check him
out in the Houston Chronicle and also at
McLane what's what's your total dress
and McClain underscore on underscore in
FL and it's it's a it's a must follow
Thank You certainly during baylor games
and it could get ugly tonight we're back
with your phone calls eight four four
two oh four rich is the number to dial
here in 60 seconds and Cincinnati the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint